let me compliment you jack by saying you
look good i think you do
you look good you you have a lot of uh
grace you clearly have stamina
well it's you know the uh camouflage
hides some of the bulk
it's just like i i kind of melt a little
into the background i have been working
on my physique a bit i've been doing a
lot of mountain climbing and biking and
trying to just
lose a couple of the lbs because i want
to live longer and just be
strong and and also my partner and my
band tenaciously kyle gass
is uh he's lost some weight and he's
lighter that he's like 225 pounds right
now
and i'm like 235 pounds right now and it
drives me insane when that happens
and so i uh decided to just lose a bunch
of weight
do you know is your technique just to
exercise more
well i yes i exercise and i also focus
on my diet but the problem is that i'm
always super hungry for macaroni and
cheese
and also cheeseburgers and there's
nothing i can do to stop myself
right um so what i did was i started
a regimen of drugs that um
prevent me from eating supposedly but i
just started the drugs and they're not
working
so i'm gonna up the dosage
i don't know what drug you're talking
about it doesn't matter i'm not gonna
here to promote my drugs
but the side effect supposedly is it
sucks out your personality
and then you're just a zombie yeah for
conan yeah
you'll be a thin zombie that's the
important worth it the worst thing i
the worst thing i hear a guy say is i
don't know i just started not church
working so i'm upping my own dosage
you're not supposed to do that i'll talk
to the doctor okay good
he's the one they call him dr field
[Applause]
filger